هي اول سفيره لدى تل ابيب في انقره منذ
عام 2018 تسلم السفير الاسرائيليه الجديده
لمنصبها يؤكد عوده الدف الى العلاقات بين
البلدين بعد سنوات من التوتر وقتيعه بدات
منذ عام 2010 على خلفيه احداث سفينه في
مرمر تركيا التي كانت متجهه الى قطاع غزه
منذ اربع سنوات تازمت العلاقات بعد ان
تبادلت الدوله ترضى دبلوماسيين على خلفيه
مقتل عشرات الفلسطينيين خلال احتجاجات على
حدود قطاع غزه في 2019 اعلنت اسرائيل
معارضتها اتفاقا بين ليبيا وتركيا لترسيم
الحدود البحريه شرق البحر المتوسط
في محاوله لتحسين العلاقات اطلقت تركيا في
2021 صراحه زوجين اسرائيليين اعتقل
لالتقاطه مع صورا لمقر اقامه اردوغان في
اسطنبول في عام 2022 زار الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اذاكر تركيا كما زار وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود جاويش اوغلو
اسرائيل خطوه عبر من خلالها طرفان عن
رغبتهما بتوسعه علاقاتهم الاقتصاديه
لتتوج العلاقات في سبتمبر عام 2022
باعاده البلددين تعيين السفراء